OF REMOVING PRESIDENT TRUMP FROM
OFFICE.
WITH US IS THE JUDICIAL WATCH
PRESIDENT TOM FENTON.
THE WORK OF JUDICIAL WATCH HAS
BEEN CRITICAL IN THIS.
YOU HAVE GOTTEN MORE
INFORMATION.
THEY HAD A STRATEGY, ROD WAS
GOING TO SAY HE WAS JUST JOKING?
TO DEFLECT FROM THE TRUTH THAT
THEY WERE NOT TALKING ABOUT?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THIS IS THE FIRST OFFICIAL
CONFIRMATION THAT ALLEGATIONS
TOOK PLACE.
THERE WAS TESTIMONY ABOUT IT.
YOU HAVE ROD ROSENSTEIN AND HIS
TEAM TRYING TO CRAFT A RESPONSE,
NON-DENIAL ON THE ALLEGATIONS.
ROSENSTEIN SAID WE ARE HOPEFUL
WE ARE SUCCESSFUL IN
PREPRESENTING PEOPLE FROM
TALKING ABOUT.
IT THEY CHANGED THE STATEMENT
FROM A DENIAL.EOPLE FROM TALKING
FROM A DENIAL.EOPLE FROM TALKINA
FROM A DENIAL.EOPLE FROM TALKINO
FROM A DENIAL.EOPLE FROM TALKINT
FROM A DENIAL.EOPLE FROM TALKIN.
IT THEY CHANGED THE STATEMENT
FROM A DENIAL.
TO A LESS CATEGORICAL DENIAL.
HE WAS SARCASTICALLY WAS TALKING
ABOUT WEARING A WIRE WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
-- THOSE DISCUSSIONS INVOLVE 3
TOPICS.
WEARING A WIRE AND IS INVOKING
THE 25th MEANT AND INVOKING THE